kids will say hey I'm I'm a conservative
I'm a libertarian I believe in certain
things but I'm afraid of saying it in
class should I say it in class or not I
said well are you willing to get the bad
grade what what they're asking is how do
i do what i want to do without paying a
price you can't you can't everything has
a cost I know your answer to this but do
you think these things should be fought
on multiple fronts meaning there can be
a more conservative answer there can be
a more libertarian answer that's more
free-market I mean that's why I started
local as it was like when I I've had
this disagreement with Tucker Carlson on
his show where he wants the government
to do it and I said well I'm gonna try
the free-market side I don't have a
problem with that argument because it's
like maybe we all have to hit it in
different ways look the Prager you guys
that you work with they got into a
lawsuit with YouTube is is Dennis's or I
don't want to speak for Dennis but it's
the Prager you ethos like let's use the
law to stop companies from doing
something of course not but we're all
we're all trying to navigate very murky
water and isn't that the freest market
of all has to try all all of these
different solutions to the problem
you're not going to be able to take down
this monstrous left-wing edifice with
one little narrow pure solution that
that one little narrow pure solution
might help but you're gonna need a lot
of different strategies a lot of
different tactics to undertake and so
certainly everything should be on the
table you don't want to do anything that
is objectively wrong I'm not advocating
that anyway but if if once a we
shouldn't just burn down the Google
servers I think you're somewhere in Utah
we shouldn't just go there and and like
mask in the name of social justice yeah
yeah I know we probably shouldn't do
that but but certainly I mean what
you've done with locals is a great
example right certainly we can innovate
we can create try to create our own
institutions at least create the
beginnings of our own institutions and
enforce the law that is already on the
books those two things are not
contradictory to one another and
actually if we do enforce the law if we
do have a credible threat of enforcing
we do have a credible threat of a
competitor to one of these organizations
that is going to increase the likelihood
of success on all fronts you know when
you've got something like Google and
when you add in all the other tech
companies they control the flow of
Internet that is an amount of power that
I don't think anybody who is who cares
deeply about the country or is or any of
the founding fathers and the people
who've thought about how this Republic
is supposed to work I don't think they
would be comfortable with that kind of
power being consolidated whether it's an
technically a private company or not
yeah does some of your belief that these
things can be stopped
is there a biblical sort of bedrock
beneath that I mean I always say if
David could be Goliath and made a Dave
could be Google like I really do believe
that that there is we it is so embedded
in us that the little guy can beat the
big guy that that makes me crazy enough
to try to start my own tech company in
the midst of all this you know that's it
that's such a great point because I
don't know that they can be beaten I
don't know that the destructive left
that has wrecked our institutions and
our our political traditions and our our
civil society I don't know that they can
be beaten or beaten in my lifetime but I
do know I should try and I do know I
have no reason not to try I mean I guess
I guess that would be maybe the the
biblical basis of it is what do I have
to lose what why would I what would I
gain by playing along and saying things
that I don't believe in and being
bullied into posting whatever I've got a
post on social media if I lose my
integrity if I lose my dignity if I lose
the things that I care about so I have a
slightly more pleasant life that's not a
compelling argument well I think a lot
of people watching this would say well I
don't want to lose my job
yeah and it's a it's a real fear the I
mean I'm sure you get this question all
the time of college campuses kids will
say hey I'm I'm a conservative I'm a
libertarian I believe in certain things
but I'm afraid of saying it in class
should I say it in class or not I said
well are you willing to get the bad
grade what what they're asking is how do
i do what i want to do without paying a
price you can't you can't
everything has a cost for me I've spoken
at I've said what I believe it has cost
me certain things I go to bed at night
I'm grinning ear to ear I sleep like a
baby I I think probably you do too yeah
it's worth it to me but there is a
costume it's interesting cuz I get that
question all the time or at least when
we were allowed to travel technologists
remember the old days and I had once
heard ben shapiro obviously give an
answer on that which was that if you're
in college that in your core classes so
meaning if you want to be a doctor in
your core classes you probably shouldn't
speak up because you do need to move
ahead yeah and you don't want to be
screwed but in some of your other stuff
you know like lesbian dance theory like
they're you maybe could speak up a
little bit more because it probably
won't take you out there was some
version of that I'm not totally sure if
that's what he feels now and for like
four or five years ago what I would say
is just suck it up and get the grade cuz
you want to get out but about four years
ago I completely changed and I started
telling them absolutely reverse you must
speak up yeah if you don't speak up
though you're if you're in college the
world will never be easier for you
you're not gonna get out of college
you're not gonna get out of college you
have a car payment and a mortgage and a
wife and a dog and all of these
responsibilities plus all the endless
nonsense of the world and suddenly be
like you know I'm gonna get brave today
lose my job let's roll yeah so you'll
never do it so that that's what I push
now but it it doesn't mean it's easy if
actually it means it's the reverse this
is the same argument as don't worry
about the snowflakes when they get to
the real world no the the real world
gets realer and realer and realer and I
understand prudence is a virtue and
politics changes with time politics is
about circumstances so maybe it made
more sense at one time to keep a little
bit quiet and then you can try to move
here but in terms of how how I would
live my life with the advice I would
give no I would say speak up doesn't
mean you need to go where you're mag
ahead every time you're at the water
cooler but but it does mean if you're
asked a question about your beliefs I
would tell people what you think I I
think it's it's a good habit to get into
let's not forget the virtues or habits
and so if you if you practice them from
a young age you're more likely to be
able to practice them at an older age
right and if you don't if you say no
when I turn sixty men then I'm gonna
start start practicing the virtues all
right I don't know if it's gonna work
and this
garrier part is that it's they I think a
lot of young people think oh it's when I
turned 22
yeah right like 60 we could all accept
that a 60 year old most likely you know
although maybe he's going through like a
later midlife crisis and then maybe is
gonna do something nuts but that
probably involves going to Vegas and you
know not practicing the virtues not
right it's not right you don't have the
right you're not gonna go the virtue
thing I'm kidding you sort of hit on
this but I'm curious what you think the
sort of future how wide a future
conservative tent can be because I'll
drop a little knowledge for you knows
I'm like I'm working on my second book
and that's kind of the direction I'm
gonna go with it
that what I'm really it seems to me that
the right broadly speaking has won the
big arguments they've won the arguments
on individual liberty they've won the
arguments on family on belief at least
in the terms of as an organizer of
society maybe not at an absolute
individual level I think we have a
little disagreement on that which
imagine to talk about but that the right
basically got the big stuff right yeah
and what I think is for some of that's
on the more liberal side of that my job
is to kind of make sure that they never
go off the deep end too far right let's
say and start coming around to like you
know trying to get violence out of video
games again like the right used to try
to do right but I know that there's
people on the right that you know want
more of a religious version of
conservatism then there's obviously the
libertarians what do you do you think
that thing can hold because I really
believe that the future of Western
politics not just in America in every
Western nation is a center-right future
I think we're seeing that happen across
the world right now yes but how why do
you think that thing can be to not to
become too big I think you you don't
need to worry as much about the breadth
as the object what you're fighting
against because I do think that there is
a lot of space on the right but it's not
going to be the same tent that we saw in
the Cold War for instance so you will
never find a greater admirer of William
F Buckley Jr and Ronald Reagan than me
okay I really admire those guys they
fought their battle they were fighting
the Soviet Union and they cobbled
together this coalition that doesn't
make a lot of sense the Coalition was
the social conservative traditionalist
religious right and they hated the
atheism of the Soviet Union
you've got the libertarians
you know practical anarcho-capitalists
on one side right they don't really care
about the religious right argument at
all but they hate the collectivism of
the Soviet Union you've got the Blue Dog
Democrats they don't really care about
either of those two things they care
about the imperial expansion of the
Soviet Union they come together they
fight the Cold War where do you think
Reagan fits in that he's more of like a
California conservative that kind of
shifted right in the midst of all that
or anybody who tells you they can
analyze Ronald Reagan is lying to you
Ronald Reagan is one of the most
enigmatic figures in American politics I
mean this is a guy he liberalized
abortion laws in California more than
anybody before him and yet he becomes
one of the most pro-life presidents in
American history it's very I mean I I
know that Bill Buckley had a major
influence on bringing Ronald Reagan over
to the right I mean I think there were a
lot of people of his generation who said
they got mugged by reality and I think
that's how you go from a New Deal
Democrat into a Reaganite conservative
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell